[Music]
you guys know that company
tyson foods yeah chicken mate
yeah beef pork chicken so they actually
produce 20
of beef pork and chicken in the u.s
yeah i need quality chicken products oh
hell nah dude
that's what i say and i stand by it a
thousand percent oh it's got the
steeping guarantee
[Laughter]
yeah so they they're like the walmart of
the uh
farming industry and they make uh like
more like private farms pretty [ __ ] up
looking
but at least they're honest with their
chickens they don't try to treat them
nice
they're very honest about what they're
there didn't they go through a scandal
because their workers were wearing
diapers and [ __ ] so they don't have
bathroom breaks and
what we went through all kinds of stuff
too damn cause i heard it
yeah i heard amazon doing that what the
heck but
yeah so rece like right now they're in
the news because
they have suspended managers at it at an
iowa plant because they are being
accused of participating in a betting
pool
on how many employees would become ill
with coven 19.
oh my god that is grounds for
who told it's [ __ ] up because they
also were not
very mindful of setting in place like
practices
for their employees to be safe and they
actually like
uh the non-english speakers they had
this they
would end up still going into work being
all sick
one employee who was vomiting and you
still made them keep working
i see it like it was just like i said
they're making our chickens sick
so they have an incentive to keep their
workers worse
they bet against that worker exactly
like because it's the managers right
whereas if i do a ghoul pool and i'm
like i think sean connery will die in
2020
and i make money off of it i had nothing
to do with sean carrey died right
or did you make sense yeah because i
thought i took it like as if like we
were all went
we're gonna go drink and then we're
betting on who's gonna get drunk first
so i just thought it was like a
friendly game of something right but
just with covent but now i see
because if they're if they're doing it
like these guys are they're racehorses
and then they're just like oh [ __ ] well
i'm trying to get 10 people sick so
we'll just keep them here
yeah so they didn't have enough uh ppe
personal protective equipment
they the the social distancing
guidelines were ignored on the plant
floor and in employee locker rooms they
also
they like employees had complained and
saying that
there were under-resourced nurses that
could not accurately conduct temperature
checks
and like i said before the non-english
english english yes
because you're turning into a
non-english speaker not english
non-english speaker speaking employees
mistakenly believed that they could
return to work while
sick and then uh what else they also
offered
500 thank you bonuses to employees who
turned up for
every scheduled shift for three months
oh wow oh regardless of
exactly and then um and then so they're
saying that
direct supervisors were like
one manager named john casey who's being
like he's one of the ones that got
suspended
explicitly directed supervisors to
ignore signs of illness
even if they were exhibiting symptoms of
covet 19 and he directed supervisors to
make their direct reports come
to work so he bet the over
i guess even he should have bet the
under because then he would have had an
incentive to keep it under to keep them
healthy yeah
yeah what was i want to know what the
stakes were uh i don't know how big was
the pool that they yeah no were they
were they like um rib eye
were they no i'm scared wow
that's not what i started to that just
kind of happened yeah right
i hope this is what you're like on
deliciousness no
it is it literally is god damn it
it literally gets to the point where
there was one little tangent where i i
would make
i made one joke one pun and no one got
it there was a cameraman he was like ah
brutal cameraman i hope they left that
in oh no no
no it's great because um it kind of
became my thing on accident just because
i like you know i like doing that
um but like but it's a there's no
audience right
so it's like the crew is the ones that
are cracking up so there's one and
they're allowed to crack up they're
allowed to crack up yeah yeah so there's
there's one camera guy specifically he
[ __ ] loves my bad puns so like
whenever i do when he's like
when there's like no one else that
laughs
i'm a pun fan too anyways so uh
yeah so there are 2 800 about 2 800
employees at this one particular plant
where all this happened so they're just
yeah they got in trouble and they're not
getting paid during their suspension as
well
so yeah that's what's tough about the
that kind of industry man
they're saying that as of may about 4
600 cases of coven 19 and 18
deaths have been linked to tyson foods
damn
the company has a whole [ __ ] ton of
employees yeah yeah they have
let me see there was a number like over
a hundred thousand employees oh [ __ ]
but not all farms are created equal
this is the coveted free farm right here
with free farm you could get at mk dot
farm slash joe for 10 off
and uh we also have employees that
can make up to around eighty thousand
dollars a year
really yes and joe bet on them not
getting corona virus which is why they
have the strictest standards
cause he put his personal guarantee on
that are you is this
a strictly a shiitake company or are you
guys doing different mushrooms as well
dude we're gonna come out with oyster
and all kinds of other stuff too but
this is our first
run at it shiitake baby you're gonna do
some [ __ ] higher end like
chanterelles and [ __ ]
those are really hard to grow in in
captivity i can't believe you know that
that's so weird
well i mean we tried everything right
well if you said high end it must be
hard to grow i see like they're coveted
for a reason like truffles
like you guys want truffle hunting you
can't grow chocolate you can't it has to
be made like in certain
parts of the world pigs pooping on it
there's only three
places main places oregon oregon
croatia and italy because truffles are
also a mushroom
fungus okay i can't believe it it's in
demand
i find it disgusting it looks like [ __ ]
in the ground delicious
fresh chocolate truffles are gross so
gross
it's all gross where did you get them
from no okay freshly i'll get grated
truffles
on some pasta i really loved some cream
pasta right
yes creamy pastas when i was given i
like chocolate a fresh i'm talking about
the booziest most expensive truffle
white truffle
it's sure okay it was one of those right
on a [ __ ]
plate myself slight i was like this
smells like
sink water it's like not smell great
yeah but
paired with some [ __ ] in the right way
yes it's great yeah
tastes like armpit but what but one time
i was at a restaurant and i knew that i
was cool to chef and he came out [ __ ]
and like hooking me up took a a a
truffle was going
to put that [ __ ] all over my thing and i
was like and i took a bite
oh no that's too bad you ruined it yeah
yeah for me i can't do truffle oil like
like a umami
i hate everything on their menu oh
because it's all truffle everything's
truffle oil is not even real truffle
it's like synthetic [ __ ] yeah i just
that flavor whatever it is
i like it yes it's overpowered you ever
watched um [ __ ] chopped or any of the
food network shows
yeah so whenever you watch chopped and
like someone grabs the truffle oil to
put on ingredient all the judges go oh
that's fine they go you ruined it you
ruined it and they hate chocolate good
yeah yeah yeah good mm-hmm
but let me know when you start going
your truffles and i don't think i'm
gonna grow it's
hard you literally can't my next round
will be oyster
mushrooms yeah they're pretty cool with
different colors too
you know what i love the um what are the
um enoki mushrooms i love you tomorrow
oh
my god are you gonna make some enoki
mushrooms enoki it's
not really worth growing it's cheaper to
just get it
you know sent over or whatever from
other farms or whatever
it's a volume game it is like it's kind
of like wheat you know like you gotta
make tons of it for it to be worth it uh
yeah i really learned so much about
mushrooms during this whole year though
it's pretty crazy
have you heard of matsutake so it's like
japanese truffles where it's like
it tastes nothing like truffle but it's
just hella expensive m-a-t-s-u
matsu t-a-k-e c-a so
they they they grow in the wild in japan
and in oregon i don't know why i think
oregon has the most closest
climate to japan or something like that
and to croatia and italy yeah
you can get uh you can grow real wasabi
there too
in oregon it's this one yeah oh those
look uh heart those look
and a little thing like that can cost
you about like 12 bucks it's
super expensive damn yeah what do you
eat it with
man it's it's in a lot of high-end
japanese cuisine like
soups or just like to flavor things with
like they would
kind of chop it up but that's my
favorite mushroom
and then i like to eat it just straight
up uh grilled on fire
with lemon and salt what's the most
common mushroom that like when you get a
pizza
you get mushrooms uh the white button i
think
okay yeah it's like that one hope of
that on the lawn
uh i don't know because they grow those
like indoors in like a
like a it's not like an outdoor thing
it's like they just
make it on a bed like yeah what about
portobello
portabellos i don't know how they're
grown like commercially
yeah but they're so big and cool looking
and they taste pretty good they're good
on barbecue
yeah i remember when i was working on
cpk and i really
like hadn't really experienced a lot in
terms of just like eating different
things and like
different mushrooms this guy came in
specifically
got the garlic cream fettuccine and was
like and can i get it with portobello
mushrooms and i was going yeah sure
wrote it down and um but then there are
these like
mushrooms you can add like a dollar
they're just like you know regular ones
you put on like a pizza and [ __ ]
and i put those on his pasta and he was
like no no i wanted portobello mushrooms
and i was like i was so confused
i was like
mushrooms and mushrooms yeah yeah yeah
right but he wanted
the reason which reminds me i saw this
thing on
twitter um so there was this like
reddit post sent to sent to me on
twitter
where there was this guy who got
really upset at his girlfriend because
and this is the girlfriend
writing this entire story so
the boyfriend got extremely upset with
the girlfriend because she
was trying to consolidate all of his
white rices into one concern
like it's just white rice like what the
[ __ ] jasmine and b
what jasmine basmati rice like long
green short grain
that's not different they're all white
rice so she mixed them all in this one
giant
crime right i'm trying to save space
what's the crime
but did it taste good though no so then
she said like the boyfriend was like you
roll in the rice like this is
this is like now he has to go and pick
every single one and
three these could deconstruct it i don't
know if it's a crime
it's not a crime i wouldn't have been i
wouldn't have been like pissed but i
would be like oh i feel like you have to
kind of cook these different rices
differently you got you ruined
you did ruin it yeah now you can use it
for porridge i guess
so that's multi what would you call it
there's multi-grain rice
where like it's like different colored
grains of rice and stuff but it's not a
mixture of different whites it's not a
mixture of different white rices yeah
it's like all the rices that you can
cook similarly
put together the equivalent of [ __ ]
that up would be like let's say
uh someone made your sandwich it's a
croissant on top and a brioche bun on
the
bottom
oh that it's sounds mixing your bread
you're mixing your grains up you know
it's like weird i don't know it's like
black beans mixed with
regular pinto yeah that's [ __ ] weird
that's weird like a couple of different
beans but it's kidney beans
taste so we're talking about long grain
short ground like they do taste
different
it tastes different what the i think
it's called how they cooked
different were you the girlfriend you
sound like i would defend this chick to
the grave bro i'll be your [ __ ]
lawyer but they cook different that's
why
yeah well that's different yeah that's
different some of them cook like
super fast some of them take forever to
cook so
man it's like a flat steak and a rib eye
you can't cook them with the same some
are sticky some are fluffy
this could be you
this is really fun
you